(garage opening)
(soft music)
- [Brad] I don't wanna
take a shot at pilots
anywhere else in the world,
but adventure means different
things to different people.
(garage opening)
- [Jessa] I think the role
of the artist is to try
and tell the story that lights your fire,
and if you can do that,
then people are going to
pick up on that energy because
you can't help contain it.
- [Brad] When Coors Light
introduced me to Jessa
and she wanted to paint
something in the environment,
I instantly thought of
Little Ring Mountain
because there's no way to climb it,
and the only way to get
here is by helicopter.
(wind blowing)
(paws scratching the floor)
- Bentley, come on.
I'm Brad Friesen.
I'm a helicopter pilot
on the west coast of
British Columbia in Canada;
and this is my copilot,
Master Bentley the dog.
He comes with me on pretty
much all my adventures.
Do you wanna go in the helicopter?
Speak!
(dog barking)
(upbeat music)
I fly helicopters to
be able to take people
and show them my backyard.
(upbeat music)
(Brad laughing)
- [Man] Dude, that was sick!
Hey, does that look real?
(helicopter blades whirring)
- My name's Jessa Gilbert.
I'm an artist based in Squamish, B.C.
I had this dream to be
able to take a big canvas
out to the back country, so
that I can create an artwork,
and then translate that
experience later on,
hopefully, into a mural in Squamish.
When I first started
painting, I thought that art
and adventuring had to exist in two silos,
so I would go and I
would work in the studio,
and then I would put that
aside, and then I would go
and snowboard and explore.
Moving to B.C. allowed me to
meld the two silos together
and to create just one uniformed identity.
I'm so excited to share
something that I find
so incredibly impactful
with the community.
I'm really nervous about it.
I hope I can do a good job.
(trunk closing)
(soft music)
- I have never worked with an artist.
I can say that.
(Brad laughing)
Especially not in the back country.
Not even in the fore country.
Is that a front country?
(helicopter blades whirring)
- [Brad] Morning!
- [Jessa] Morning!
How was your flight?
- It was good once we got the
fuel truck out of the way,
it was awesome.
(dog panting)
OK, so, uh.
We're gonna follow the Squamish River,
and then this will be
Little Ring right there.
- It's so cool to get and
to look at more the tops
of the peaks, rather than
seeing it from the valley.
- Yeah, I'm so stoked, yeah.
Instead of this, you'll be doing that.
And it's not climbable; it's not something
that people can get to
without a helicopter.
- Even cooler.
You're gonna get us there!
- Yeah. Alright
(helicopter blades whirring)
Hey, it's Squamish traffic R44, helicopter
Golf Yankee Yankee Whiskey plus one.
Northbound up the Squamish
River. Any conflicting? Golf Yankee Yankee Whiskey
- [Man] K, copy that, thanks.
(Jessa laughing)
- [Jessa] That's crazy.
- [Brad] Heading Northbound at 1,500 feet.
- We're goin' right in it.
- Oh, yeah, we're going right into it.
(helicopter blades whirring)
(soft music)
- Ring and then lower.
- Wow, they really stand out in the range.
(helicopter blades whirring)
- [Brad] Bentley!
- It's incredibly humbling being up here
because you realize how small you are
in the grand scheme of things.
You don't even make a blip in the radar.
I wanted to see the
terrain that was around
to get the best orientation
and the best composition.
The problem was that
everything is stunning.
I did four or five
sketches and it was like
I don't know how I'm
actually gonna choose this.
Every time I walked around
the peak, you get another view
that has something incredible about it.
(reverent music)
That one stuck out to me because
not only is it the texture
of the landscape, but it tells the story
of how we arrived here.
It shows the way in which
we navigated through
and also the similarity
in the landscape that
we're experiencing right here.
Do you mind helping me set up my studio?
- I like helping.
(Brad and Jessa laughing)
- [Brad] Wow!
- This is definitely the most back-country
my easel has ever been.
(supplies unrolling)
(pen brushing across canvas)
The technique that I
use for these creations is
called a single line.
The goal is that once the pen
touches down on the panel,
it never comes up.
(wind blowing)
The reason why I like this
technique is that it requires
that you're fully engaged in
your practice and your process
the entire time you're
creating the landscape.
(footsteps)
- Whoa. This is awesome.
- Thanks!
- It's really cool.
Temperature's dropping,
how are you feeling that?
- Uh, probably wrap up
once the sun goes down.
- Sun's gone down; I dunno
if you noticed or not.
- Well, once that disappears.
(Brad and Jessa laughing)
(wind blowing)
(footsteps crunching)
- What time do you think
you're gonna get up and start?
- I'd love to be up for sunrise.
- Whoa, cool.
-You have fun.
(Brad and Jessa laughing)
(wind blowing)
(peaceful music)
(equipment clinking against rocks)
(liquid pouring)
(footsteps on rocks)
(fingers sliding on canvas)
- There's always this tension about coming
back to the painting the
next day after you leave it
the night before about what
does it actually look like.
Is it capturing that moment?
What I wanna capture is
really just how it feels
to spend time outside
and feel the landscape
and feel connected to it.
Hopefully I don't screw it up.
(laughing)
I hope that the painting that I
create can really showcase
and celebrate what it
feels like to be up here
because it's incredible.
- Just watching Jessa telling
the story of where we are,
what she's doing here, is
gonna translate incredibly well
to the final mural.
I think it's gonna have a lot of meaning
for a lot of people.
(upbeat music)
- I hope to do this again.
I'm so -- I'm filled.
It's amazing.
(upbeat music)
(wind blowing)
This is a beast.
The larger the wall, the bigger the risk,
and the bigger impact
it can potentially make.
I wanna make sure that
I'm giving the community
something that they can be proud of.
(spray paint can shaking)
(calming music)
(wind blowing)
Tomorrow morning, early, I
have some helpers coming.
I'm still nervous about how
I'm going to tell people
what I need and that I
don't totally blow it
'cause I got a lot of work to do.
(upbeat music)
This is starting to look really good, guys.
- We're almost here.
Is this is it?
You ready? Jump!
- Hi, how's it going?
How've you been?
- Good.
This is it?
- This is it. Yeah.
Plugging away, day two.
- Wait, so, I don't
remember palm trees on top
of a mountain.
- They're not palm trees!
They're ferns, Brad.
(cars driving)
Today was a really productive day.
I go into what I call
the creative blackout.
I lose track of time, I
suddenly kinda wake up
a couple hours later.
(peaceful music)
I'm thinking a lot about
what Squamish means.
Depending on what First Nation
you ask, it means either
Mother Wind or Strong Wind.
The reason that the
clouds are so playful here
is because of that wind, that energy.
I wanna make sure that that
wind gets visually articulated
in the piece somehow.
We'll see.
(chuckling)
(wind blowing)
(soft music)
(people talking)
I got fully in my headphones
and when I turned around,
there was like fifty people here.
(laughing)
- Hey, how ya doing?
I've never had anybody interpret a ride.
She's taken sort of the essence of flying,
and she's translated the whole
trip from not only the colors
but the feeling of getting
to the environment.
(Jessa laughing)
- I wanna be able to share
the joy and the gratitude
I have for these places with
as many people as possible.
That's what's kinda nice
about the mountains is
nobody owns them.
Thank you so much for coming out.
This is -- I might cry.
(laughing)
Ah, this is a really big moment.
There are so many dreams that came true
with this whole project.
I got to make a public piece
of art in the town that I love,
that I live in.
(people cheering)
- Everybody, cheers to
Jessa, this amazing artwork,
and this great town that inspired it.
(people cheering)
- This landscape changed me
into a better version of myself,
and I hope that the artwork
that I make and this mural
can help inspire other
people to get outside
and perhaps get on their own adventures.
(upbeat music)
(toned bell sounding)